we're wrapping up my healthy habits for
the new year with one that really
applies to everyone but more often times
speaks to women of all ages how well do
you love your body and how do you gauge
if it measures up
i think the best thing we can do is to
get out of the comparison race right so
even thinking to myself i'm every bit as
beautiful as she is or you know i still
measure up still means that we are
comparing ourselves to somebody else's
standard other than our own life coach
deb grayson regal says with different
body types different metabolisms and
different goals in life it's impossible
to define beauty the same and if you are
going to
unlearn a lifetime of comments about
positive body means a certain size or
shape you've got to be really patient
with yourself and expect there to be
setbacks along the way regal says if you
have doubts try to analyze the internal
feedback you get when you see your
reflection so when you look at yourself
in the mirror ask yourself what you're
feeling am i feeling disappointed am i
feeling ashamed embarrassed and be
willing to to name it and then see if
you can replace it with a more helpful
healthier thought social counselor jacob
cooper says keeping the spotlight on
your own values and what truly matters
in your life will shelter you from the
negative noise instead of focusing on
what's outside finding ways to set your
own intentions within your life and to
focus on the news that you want to
create or the story that you want to
tell executive life coach adam jablin
says pick your posse of positive people
and avoid or limit your time around
those who aren't make sure you're with
the right people friends family and
there is power and being able to like
i say with like a boxer bob and we go in
for a few minutes be with your loved
ones bow out because if you're hearing
negative enforcement
you can't sit in that you have to get
out deb regal says if you're seeking
positive change craft healthy goals and
keep them attainable body positivity may
be a little bit too far of a reach if
you've got it good for you for me i'm
working on body neutrality right so to
get from uh what is this to
this is me she urges ultimately as you
train yourself to love who you are
inside and out always try to set
yourself up for success i can get some
new clothes that make me feel awesome
is probably a healthier thought or you
can borrow mine which is
the necklace is always going to fit
that's so easy to remember well all the
life coaches i spoke with say staying
away from the negative influences of
social media and the glam magazines will
definitely help too but you know once
deb said that she said look in the
mirror what emotions do you get what
reaction do you get when you look at
yourself in the mirror and if it's
negative
face those negative feelings what is it
that's making you feel that way and meet
it head-on don't just go oh i don't want
to look in the mirror because that's
stuff you got to process and you got to
get through that and then you got to
figure out how to start looking for the
healthy stuff the positive things to say
about yourself and feel good about
yourself because if there's something in
here that's not working when you look at
this
then that needs to be worked like the
adult brain can comprehend that but then
you wonder about the younger girls you
know who are sitting on social media
which we didn't have growing up and
seeing the constant you know filters and
yep there's a lot of comparison going on
out there there's gonna be years before
we see the effect of all of that social
media negativity ladies yeah that's true
so be positive girls got a lot of great
stuff to offer all right and